foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Albert Breer senior NFL
reporter lead content strategist for the
Monday Morning Quarterback uh does the
NFL do this name Awards after former
players
well they did the Walter Payton award I
mean that was that was I think
previously just the man of the year if I
remember right and then I believe when
was it when Walter Payton passed that
they yeah they named it after him I
think so but what about like the MVP if
I said regular season MVP in the NFL who
would you name the award after I mean I
guess like on the Jordan premise it
would be Tom Brady right like because I
you know I I don't know like I heard
what you said there on on Jordan versus
Kareem and you know Kareem won more MVPs
but I mean I grew up in the 90s and I
remember it was like he could have won
it every year and it was almost like I
can't remember like Charles Barkley
wanted 93 no one thought Charles Barkley
was a better player that year than
Michael Jordan no respect to to to
Charles Barkley
um I think Carl Malone won it like 97 or
98 right so you know I I think like it's
about the greatest player and the
greatest player is Tom Brady so I I
think he'd probably name it the Tom
Brady MVP who board right
um no I would do Peyton Manning and then
I would have the Super Bowl MVP Tom
Brady that makes sense that makes some
sense yeah yeah do you think Peyton
would take that as a slap in the face
you know what I mean like
um I I would hope that he would
understand that hey I was a great
regular season quarterback and I had
more MVPs than Tom but facts are facts
here Albert Tom's your MVP when it came
to the biggest game you know of the year
no question yeah that that'd be
interesting though because like I did
they name the Rookie of the Year after
someone in in basketball is there a name
for that one will Chamberlain
okay okay because like you go through
those different ones like would it be
like the Randy Moss Rookie of the Year
because you remember Randy was such a
comment as a rookie you know what I mean
like
I'd be it'd be interesting to go through
them like Lawrence Taylor defensive
player of the year I think's easy right
like I think it'll probably be LP yep so
yeah there's some interesting arguments
there Jerry Rice offensive player of the
year could do that I always hated when
they did offensive player of the year
and then they did MVP
right because it's like how is the MVP
the MVP is always an offensive player so
how is the MVP not the offensive player
of the year when I vote on those things
I always I always try to make this like
best individual performer and I feel
like it's almost become the best
non-quarterback award right oh yeah the
MVP so it's almost always like like this
year I think I think most people
probably vote for Justin Jefferson for
offensive player of the year
is the MVP award Jalen hurts to lose
it's a great question I mean I I yeah I
mean I I mean look like I think I did a
poll on this um a few of the mid-season
point so after nine weeks and um I can't
remember how many Executives but it was
I don't know 50 or something like that
and the answer was overwhelmingly
Patrick Mahomes and
I think like it's interesting the way we
do these things because sometimes it's
just like well and it's like I think
Mahomes has almost entered into that
Brady Jordan category where it's like he
could probably win it every year and
like if you look at like what homes has
accomplished
without Tyreek Hill you know like Tyreek
Hill leaves there and they bring in you
know Valdez scantling and JuJu Smith
Schuster and all these new guys Sky
Moore the rookie and like they haven't
really missed a beat and they've carried
a defense that's had its issues like the
defense had serious problems in Denver
last weekend you know what I mean like
and so I think what Jalen hurts has done
is phenomenal and sometimes like we
almost treat the MVP award as the
Breakthrough performer you know what I
mean like it's the guy who is on a
really great team who took a huge step
and Jalen hurts fits that like Jalen
hurts fits like what Mahomes was in 2018
right where he's like sort of the
Breakthrough guy for a really great team
but I mean if we're talking about value
to a franchise I think it's really
really hard to beat my homes especially
this year when they lost somewhat when
they lost such an important piece around
and changed out so many people around
him
you got some awkward quarterback
situations coming up
short term long term Seattle
you're going to stay with what you have
you got a high draft pick here
um you know the lions with Jared Goff
if he makes the playoffs there what the
Ravens have uh the short term long term
the Rams what they have Baker Mayfield
the Packers what they have like if you
were going to do
like prioritize the most awkward
quarterback situation where would you
start
um
the Raiders are interesting
um because they haven't had the success
that they
envisioned I think
um you know I I think the guys who went
in there Josh McDaniels Dave Ziegler
thought they were closer than maybe they
were and you don't do things like
trading for Devonte Adams and signing
Chandler Jones if you don't think you're
close and um so you think they could
really move on from well I mean the
reason I bring them up first is because
they're the first one that's going to
have to make a decision because there's
a thing in um there's an element of
Derek Carr's contract where 40 million
dollars vest is fully guaranteed I think
it's three days after the Super Bowl so
they're gonna have to make a decision on
Derek Carr in the middle of February at
a time when two quarterbacks who played
for Josh are probably going to be
available and Tom Brady and Jimmy
Garoppolo both those guys obviously have
open road to free agency so
that's one that's really interesting and
I think we'll get an answer on that one
before we get an answer on the others
okay
um
as far as which one's most awkward
I mean I guess Green Bay just because
you know like you're at that point with
your love or you're gonna have to make a
decision on his fifth year option
um you know that coming that's coming in
May you've got this you know just
massive contract that gives Aaron
Rodgers a ton of control over the
situation
um that one I think is at least
interesting and if Aaron lets his
decision it like allows for his decision
to bleed into March you know then that
has potential to really kind of
you know kind of handcuffed the Packers
as far as they're planning you know and
so that one's a little awkward
um I don't think Seattle's that awkward
I mean I think Seattle they try to sign
Geno Smith and you know I think Geno
becomes like the
like Alex Smith in Kansas City I know
I've used that example with you in the
past where like you feel comfortable
with Gino's your starting quarterback is
he going to be your starting quarterback
forever no but he can help you get to
the next one and you can win with him
and he's shown that already you know so
I I don't think Seattle's quite as
awkward as say Green Bay or Vegas will
be once the season ends we're talking to
the Monday Morning Quarterback Albert
Breer the Brady situation
I it feels fluid that you know you can
see the frustration he probably realizes
the ceiling is you know not that high
and if you could go someplace where you
add water and stir and he's that guy
that you're stirring the Raiders seems
like a really interesting landing spot
there uh yeah
you see that as a real possibility
yeah I think it's on the table like I I
think I I mean I don't know if he's
going to play next year right like so I
I don't think he knows if he's going to
play next year
um you know obviously he's been through
a lot personally in the last few months
and I think that's a factor when it
comes to all of this you know as kids
are getting older
um but you know I I do think that
there's like an appreciation for some of
the things that he had in New England
now you know
um the way he was coached in New England
the way the operation ran in New England
and so I think if he's going to keep
playing it's going to be in a place
where he doesn't need to run the whole
thing and I think there have been times
in Tampa where he's felt like he was
responsible for a lot of different
things around him and keeping things
straight and um you know even down to
like the off-season program the way
they're in the off-season program the
last few years like post covid was the
young players would come in and work
with the coaches and then Brady would
take the vets and they would sort of
work on their own off-site you know and
um and so like I think going to a place
where there's more structure and maybe
he can just go and play would probably
appeal to him and I think like Vegas and
San Francisco could offer those
situations now San Francisco's
quarterback situation is obviously fluid
but they flirted with it before they
left the light on for him last year I
think they would consider it if Brady
would consider them after this year and
then Vegas is obvious because there are
pieces in place I think Brady probably
believes people would follow him there
and obviously there's a lot of you know
carryover in what he did for 20 years in
New England with what they're trying to
build there do we know the official
reason why Bruce Arians is no longer the
coach in Tampa
I genuinely think he wanted to give Todd
Bowles like I genuinely think that that
was the biggest thing was he wanted to
give Todd Bowles the chance to run the
show and he wanted to give Todd Bowles
the chance to have a winning team and he
felt and I I think that there was a
belief that the Clock Was sort of
ticking on that group and you know there
was only he wasn't going to get very
many swings at handing this over to a
guy that he loved and Todd
um were things perfect between he and
Brady no there was definitely friction
you know but I think the bigger factor
for Bruce was kind of like looking at it
globally and saying
if I have my ring it just sort of feels
like time for me and I want to do
something for a guy that I think the
world of and he and Todd I mean ba is
close to a lot of his coaches but but he
and Todd are like they're like family
you know and so I think that that was
maybe the biggest factor in in walking
away when he did Kyler Murray's injury
have any impact on Lamar Jackson's
contract
it's an interesting question because it
was such a freak injury you know what I
mean like I feel like that sort of could
have happened to anybody like that
wasn't about Kyler Murray being an
athletic quarterback who gets out on the
edge and runs right like that was more
yeah he was doing that when he got hurt
but I mean it could have happened
anywhere on the field
um so I don't know how much it factors
into the way the Ravens approach Lamar
because I think the Ravens are committed
to paying Lamar I think the question is
and will continue to be is Lamar willing
to take a conventional quarterback
contract or does Lamar want to do
something groundbreaking like what
DeShaun Watson did with his contract and
that's sort of where the Divide was you
know and um so
like any different franchise them I
think that they they try to get them
done on a conventional quarterback
contract I I like it's sort of I I think
at the end in the the summer sort of
turned into a staring contest and who's
gonna blink first and the Ravens have
handled this very carefully um because
they know trust is such a big thing to
Lamar and they wanted to handle
everything with him man-to-man and they
didn't want any of the negotiation being
held in the public forum and um I think
they'll continue to handle it that way I
think they they genuinely want to get
Lamar done
um as much as anything else Dan because
like if they they're so built around him
yeah like what would they do if they
didn't have him you know what I mean
it's not like there's like an easy
answer to replace Lamar Jackson when he
built that way
Cliff Kingsbury safe in Arizona
oh I don't I I'm not sure I mean I like
I don't think it's like I don't know if
it's totally out of the realm of
possibility there's like a mutual
parting I I it just feels to me like
there's a lot going on there
um and like I think like the biggest
thing that is standing in the way of
everything is the contract and things
were so awkward there Dan at the end of
the year like they canceled a number of
personnel meetings that are like these
are like normal like end of the year
Personnel meetings like wrap up talk
about this player that player those
normal like Scouts and coaches go
through the roster evaluate everything
they canceled a couple of those abruptly
and after they got blown out by the Rams
that was on Monday night I think really
like Friday of that week there were a
lot of people in that building who were
wondering if they were gonna get fired
so you went from that to like a month
later the GM and the coach have
five-year extensions and are signed
through 2027 and you've got an ownership
group that isn't flush with cash that
generally hasn't liked to blow the whole
thing up if you look like when they're
fired when they fire people over the
years they've generally been half
measures and doesn't like to eat
contract and there are five years left
on the contracts of Steve Keim and Cliff
Kim's library and so I think as much as
I think that 100 like everyone's job
would be on the line there right now if
those contracts hadn't been done and
then the question becomes how do they
get out of this does Cliff want to go
forward you know with the team it does
you know like like how do they view
Steve Khan like there are so many
unanswered questions that I think are
going to demand some tough conversations
over the next month in that building
I'll try to phrase this correctly so you
understand it but who overplayed their
hand more the media covering Odell
Beckham Jr or Odell Beckham Jr
you mean like the proclamations that
he's going to be ready in a he's ready
to roll and all of that uh
nobody asked the one the one question
that drove me crazy Albert is can when
can you play when Can you play right no
I mean and look like I think
I mean what I what he said turned some
people off like what he said on like
Amazon like I I know that turns some
people off like because there was like a
sort of like and I think Odell did a lot
to repair his reputation over the last
year but when you've got players who are
fighting through things to get through
December and like a guy just flat out
says like like I don't really see the
point playing in the regular season
there are some people that are wondering
and now this guy and now he wants like
and actually he wants another year on
the contract like you're gonna have some
pause there so
um look like he had like he was not
healthy last year and I think there's a
part of this that you know goes back to
last year and the Rams trying to when
the Rams signed him and I think I said
this to you last week like they they um
when they signed him it was like we
don't think
like if if you're if we were if we look
at the the this MRI if we looked at like
this physical and and it was September
we wouldn't sign you because we wouldn't
think you could make it to the end of
the season but because we're near the
end of the season we think we can get
you to the finish line and they almost
got him there and um and so like I think
like he's cognizant of the knee I think
he wants to go to a winning situation
because he knows and I've said this to
you before too like he knows what
playing for the Rams did for his image
last year and did for the way people
think of him last year and yet like he
comes out and he says this and it's like
if you're one of these teams that's in
it fighting for a championship are you
worried about what that might do to your
man to the mix of your team and so
um you know I I think but the Cowboys
the the the the the bills you see them
make moves this week and I think they
have left the door open but as we've
sort of seen the Chiefs go get Kadarius
Tony before the trade deadline and then
the bills signed Cole Beasley and the
Cowboys signed T.Y Hilton you see like
this sort of implicit message coming
from these teams that is hey we'll leave
we'll we'll leave the door open but I
think we've learned that if we're
bringing you in we have to treat you
like anything we get from you as a bonus
and
that's why I think like the next few
weeks is gonna kind of come down to what
Odell wants out of the rest of this year
and um
you know I like look we've all seen it
sometimes people get hurt and there
could be something happening that
happens somewhere that opens the door
and Odell gets everything he wants but
obviously these meetings
um you know I think indicated certain
things to teams whether being careful
with them I want you on record uh the
Rams starting quarterback next year will
be
on record
um
I'm gonna I'm going to
cautiously say Matthew Stafford because
I don't think he wants to go out like
this but I don't think it's a sure thing
he's back
and I think Baker Mayfield
would have a chance to be their starting
quarterback at least the bridge
quarterback if Matthew decides to move
on and I think like it's I think it's
more than just one thing with Matthew
like it's how is the arm you know
because they had to manage that during
camp and everything else and that's
something that he's dealt with over the
last few years so it's the concussion
thing it's how's the arm it's physically
where is he at because like I've said to
you before I don't think this is a guy
who's hanging around until he's 43 years
old like I think when it's time he's
going to be ready to walk away and maybe
that time is a month from now I'm just
not certain on it and I wouldn't want to
predict that before you know before
before I really before you know that
physically he feels like he can't go
anymore I sounded like I was on 60
Minutes when I said to Albert I want to
get you on record give me give me this
on record here
um thanks for uh thanks for joining us
as always Albert all right thanks Dan
that's the Monday Morning Quarterback
Albert Breer yeah I sound like a real
journalist there I'm going to ask the
tough questions I want you on record I
ordered a code red there